I've never had pizza with sprinkles on  it I think I'd like that because in  England is weird to put sweet and savory  together that sounds ok I mean like I'm  not gonna like not try it thank you so  much  looks like you did this accidentally  this seems confusing this is like a  dream sequence I'm gonna take an  Instagram of this it's so pretty how you  can pizza my mouth is very confused  you know you get like a sprinkle in the  back of your teeth so I have like  sprinkles in the back of my teeth and  I'm mad at you for that  obviously I like peas or sprinkles I  don't know how it would be if you had  like like pepperoni and other things on  top my mouth is separating the pepperoni  and the pineapple and the normal food  from the sprinkles right now you got  chills  if I be rolled in a stone person I feel  like have eerily similar kitchen idea I  don't know